[Music]
gain visibility into your cloud costs
with Google cloud cost management tools
Google cloud billing reports provide
visibility into your current cost trends
and forecasted cost billing reports help
you answer fundamental cost questions
including how much am i spending what
are my cost trends what are my cost
drivers will show you how to answer each
of these let's start by understanding
how much you're currently spending here
your actual cost for the selected time
period here your forecasted costs for
the selected time period in the line
chart you can see your daily cost group
by project each color refers to a
specific project you can see the daily
cost for each project by hovering over
the chart and quickly compared to the
total cost for the day with the chart
you can also see how much you are
forecasted to spend during this time
period you can reconcile cost with your
invoice amount by toggling to invoice
month and scrolling down to the bottom
costs are broken out by project with
promotions discounts and taxes now let's
view our actual cost by usage date over
the last 30 days similar to the previous
view you can see your cost trends and
compare your costs to previous periods
you can further refine your cost views
by selecting additional filters such as
locations labels or credits you can
filter by geography region and multi
region to gain greater insight into your
cost trends by location you can filter
by user labels applied to resources for
further granularity you can also filter
out promotions and discounts such as
sustained use discounts and committed
use discounts now that you understand
the report filters available let's look
at what caused the recent spike in cost
you can quickly identify the associated
project by hovering over the chart now
that we've identified the project we can
filter to the specific project and group
by product to further and
to gate it looks like bigquery calls the
spike we can find out more by grouping
the cost by skill
it looks like the spike and bigquery
cost was due to intensive queries being
run at that time check out some more
best practices for google cloud cost
management